so that you don't have to keep doing it
shutting it off oh so that's I can quiet
off
okay I think we're all here it's 1 o00
so I don't have a gavel but call the
median to order do I need to do anything
things get them going yeah okay I don't
have much to say we've all introduced
ourself this morning um if anybody has
anything they like to add this would be
I guess a good time but otherwise I'm
just going to introduce Mickey and let
him go forth is that is that all right I
guess I'll welcome our new members I um
uh represent Kelly and representative Dy
who are new to the house and well not
really new to the house but sort of new
to the house and um and new to finance
committee so welcome to both of you
happy to have you and I'll turn it over
to you
Mickey landan thank you represent uh for
the record my name is uh Mickey landrian
uh you see it listed as Mick landrian
here or there my real name is Michael
Mickey's Fine you can call me that um
I've been with the office for almost 18
years now I've been doing budget work
since the 2011 session was my first
budget so and uh that first year I was
with division one every year since I've
been in division 2 so this has become
pretty familiar territory for me um most
of the members here were here last year
with division 2 um I know we have two
brand new members representative Kelly's
not brand new to the house she knows the
uh very familiar so it's good to see her
um but yeah I can get right into it I
don't know if you wanted to at some
point today talk about just how the
division runs differently from how the
full committee as as we're a
subcommittee and I can kind of assist
with that um before we get into anything
anything else so uh this is a
subcommittee of house finance so uh a
lot of the same
procedures are followed but it is much
more informal than across the way so we
all this committee will do is
essentially give recommendations to the
full committee for exec we don't have
exec sessions in here we don't have
public hearings in here uh any public in
so just a question on that um because I
know you and I talked about this and
that's what you said but again this
morning uh chairman wer said I think you
were still there when he said we we'll
have a we'll have full public hearings
here and and then they'll go to the the
Committees he he used the term hearings
I think he probably meant meetings um we
won't have public hearings in here we'll
have work sessions in here on bills and
of course on House Bill one and two like
the budget but just for the two new
members we do vote in here you vote in
division two don't you we do we vote to
make recommendations correct so
um uh bills will be referred to us after
the full committee has the public
hearing we'll schedule a work session on
those bills on those days and then yeah
we'll vote on you know same motions an
ought to pass a retain itl whatever and
and recommend that back to the full
committee at which a motion will be made
in the full committee which is what the
division recommended and then the
official vote will be in the full
see yeah EV I'll
remember um just to I guess you
historically just to put it out there
for new members and uh let me know um
chair if you you will agree uh we've
always been open to having testimony or
hearings from you know the public that
they've always been able to participate
and you know give their perspective on
things and we've been able to listen to
them um that's been the way it's been
since I've been on finance and just to
iterate that hopefully that will
continue that's fine with me um but give
me a heads up that when you're wanting
to do that
anybody well we did division three to
but we didn't just like let anybody's
rip up there and start shooting the
breeze we okay okay yeah so so that's
the point from a technical perspective
I'm saying like the public will always
have uh a public hearing on all pieces
of legislation including the budget H
Bill one and two will have its own
separate public hearing uh and then when
it comes to division work when we're
doing work sessions that's the
prerogative of the committee of the
chair to invite whomever uh agency folks
Advocates lobbyists public to to input
uh but that would be up to the committee
long so I'm trying to think of other
just
general division 2 procedural things I I
clerk represent where does that
stand thank
you yes representative I just wanted to
add my thanks to representative DY for
agreeing to serve as a clerk especially
as a you know first term member first
term on finance it stuff but we'll offer
all the support that you need thank you
be able to focus on what's being said
rather than trying to interpret what
said so I'll need all of your help and
and patience so tap him if you want me
to slow down because I'm I talk quickly
but I'm glad to slow down whenever have
no problem with
that and as far as recordkeeping to that
point um all the meetings will be be
recorded and streamed on YouTube uh the
microphones are important because the
the audio will not pick it up if you're
not speaking into a microphone it is a
small room and you know we can hear each
other but nothing will be picked up on
the stream unless we're in in a
microphone so that's important to just
remember to flip it on every time we're
we're
speaking um as far as scheduling uh as
of right now you probably all got the
notices um that we do have some agency
presentations coming up next week we're
open uh starting the week of the 27th
we'll have uh higher education on uh
that day Monday the 27th fishing game
safety and Dot the 29th and then that
following week we'll have two separate
days of Department of Education to come
in to talk about some state aid programs
uh the purpose of these oh go ahead just
one moment I'm sorry to interrupt but
that kind of information you don't need
to take notes because that's in the
calendar okay so you'll you'll kind of
learn what you don't need about the
writing
down go ahead actually push the thing
actually I went to see J Janet and she's
going to give me samples of what has
been done in the past so that I can take
those home with me and kind of study
them and see what's important in in the
group but if somebody has something
special they want written down for today
I think all you have to do is is state
that our LBA um um Mr landan provid us
an overview of the procedures for the
committee and um the overview of what
we're going to be doing that's probably
enough pretty much the time we start the
time we
end yeah we we started at
nose so the purpose of those initial
hearings is really to familiarize our
new members with some of the subject um
subjects in the agencies you'll be
dealing with uh as well as a refresher
for the returning members it's a meet
and greet there may be some new people
at the Departments that weren't there
two years ago uh and it's good to get
some exposure and uh some information
prior to when the budget is handed to us
I think just getting a little bit of a
head start just helps and makes us more
efficient in the time that we do have
and speaking of the time we do have I
did uh you know not to panic anybody so
I did do a count of how many days I I do
have um March 26th as our is what we
should Target as it's Wednesday March
26th as the target date to have the
division done all of its recommendations
have be done all of its work um and that
will include um House Bill one and two
as well as any other bills that get
referred to us as of right now only five
bills have been referred to finance and
none of them are division two which is
good so we have nothing to start but at
some point we will get possibly still
first committee bills but definitely
second committee bills that we'll have
to work on um so between February 18th
which is the Monday following the
holiday weekend when the budget comes
out until the 26th including the 26
there's 27 business days in there
whether whether we have a break or not
that could be five or up to five the
school vacation week last year during
that period there were six house session
days so those are six days we're not
going to have one day is town meeting
day and one day we will have a public
hearing on House Bill one and two so
those are ones we know of that's that
brings us down to 14 days plus or minus
the vacation week but then we'll also
have public hearings on other bills
we'll also have work sessions on other
bills we're going to get so the amount
of time that we have is somewhat limited
so we just need to remember to be as
efficient as we can with the days we
have repres g m thank you Mr chair which
is why I would you know suggest like we
always do that we frontload our meetings
as we've been doing and continue to be
aggressive in frontloading them because
anything we can take care of in Terms of
General background before we have the
actual budget and start working on the
numbers would be you know work out of
the and then we can focus on the hard
part and I should just add something
here um you know we talked about the
government with the agency budgets but
we didn't talk about that but I think we
briefly mentioned that this morning and
then the governor's budget the agency
budgets are currently available online
so those can be uh downloaded
electronically um and they provide the
information about what the agencies have
requested based on what governor
sonunu previous governor sonunu had
suggested last summer when he when they
started their process of you looking at
a 4% budget cut so if you want to get a
heads up on the budget you can actually
start looking at them they're
available no it's a great Point uh the
agency budget requests have also last
year's actual expenditures this current
Year's um authorized budget as well as
like what the agencies are requesting
for the next two years and a lot of
narrative in there about separate
programs different accounting units so
especially for the new members it's a
massive document but you could hone in
on just our division two agencies and
probably learn a little bit to get ready
for um when the budget does come to us
in addition all of the agencies did do a
presentation to the governor's uh budget
director and and some staff uh relative
to those budget requests and all of them
had a handout so those handouts are also
posted online and I'll email that link
to the committee and those are good
useful documents to just kind of
familiarize yourself with just to do a
little homework on your own and in fact
the if you download the pdf version of
the agency budget
requests those also include not just the
doesn't look just like hb1 but it also
has a bunch of related notes that go
with every one of the different um
categories that you can read about if
you want to know why they're why they
things so that's kind of what the
Outlook is as far as uh scheduling um
kind of back to what our office can
provide and and does provide so Mike
Kane went through it this morning won't
dive into all that again but as far as
for division 2 I'm I'm your analyst so
I'm your guy um I'll be in here every
day we're meeting uh I will be in the
full committee when we have public
hearings or exec sessions on bills that
we're uh will be assigned to division 2
um if you have any questions you can
reach out to me our contact information
was there even if it's for new members
to understand something or experienced
members to dive into a bill or what
anything just reach out to me um
amendments to that came up this morning
there's going to be a lot of amendments
for house pill 2 you may want to draft
an amendment for one of the bills that's
in our committee just I can assist with
that if I found it's just easier to uh
if I'm part of that process I can just
kind of keep everything focused and and
make sure nothing falls through the
cracks for the committee um that kind of
covers most of
that does anyone have any questions
either from this morning's presentation
prepared so I did hand out a couple
documents nothing is brand new it's
stuff that's either been online or even
was part of your packet this morning uh
one is the kind of a lot of numbers the
agency budget um requests high level
department totals and we'll start with
that one so what I've done here is just
highlighted our agencies so in in
division 2 we'll be responsible for the
Department of
Safety the fishing game department the
Transportation Department of Education
the uh Lottery Commission the police
standards and training and the
university system of New Hampshire and
the community college system of New
Hampshire so in a nutshell you know
safety fishing game Transportation
education um
so we don't have a whole lot of agencies
but we have a lot of money and a lot of
programs within those
agencies we don't if you look on the
first page this is all funds it's the
front and back of that first uh page and
then if you look on the next one it's
just general funds only we don't have a
ton of General funds in division 2 once
you back out the higher education
University and the community college
system we don't have a ton of General
funds appropriated within division 2
that's said we have a lot of Education
trust funds a lot of Highway funds
Turnpike funds federal funds restricted
accounts fishing game funds so that's
one of the nuances of division two is
there's a lot of different fund
types and so just to be clear especially
for the the new folks education trust
funds are very similar to General funds
from the standpoint of they're coming
from the general taxes and things that
we collect there's some special things
that go into the education trust fund
and there's limitations on what the
education trust funds can be used for
but they're different from federal funds
they're different from your Highway
funds which is the tolls or the gas gas
tax the road toll High F Highway fund is
the road toll which is also the gas tax
yeah and then the turnpike fund is the
toll booths yeah so that's yeah it's so
those are sort of special but in terms
of Education trust funds just so you're
you're familiar with it there're they're
similar to General funds in terms of
their where they come from but they have
some restrictions on the education trust
funds in terms of what they can be used
for
so so like I said I gave you this just
as a reference just so it's clear which
agencies we will be looking at which
budgets we'll be looking at uh the next
document I handed out I I'm not even
going to really go into it uh that
snapshot that our office presented to
the Ways and Means Committee at the
Joint economic briefing earlier this
week that's just for your your reference
in case you didn't already see that many
of you probably have or uh know the
number but that's a document that's
going to change almost daily it's
already different from when we publish
it Monday so as revenues are coming in
as spending occurs as the uh annual
comprehensive financial report is
audited and finaly those numbers are
going to move
around and then the third document I
gave you this is one that you'll see
somewhat routinely at least the last
page of it so this is the final packet
of recommendations from house house
finance division 2 from two years ago so
this was the house bill one and
two uh DEC or recommendations that this
committee made and it kind of gives you
a glimpse of the tracking sheets that we
we will use here that I'll update every
time we meet essentially with the uh
recommendations made to date and the
pending recommendations that you still
have to figure out so for this first
page is uh essentially just all the
sections from House Bill one the back of
house bill one and House Bill 2 so last
year when House Bill 2 was introduced uh
80 some odd sections of of the Bill were
referred to division two so each one one
of those this committee will have to go
through and decide do you like it do you
want to support it do you want to delete
it do you want to amend it so all of
those this committee will have to vote
on and back to votes um
typically typically it's a show of hands
in here but we definitely have done roll
calls too and that's up to the chair to
decide of the committee to collectively
decide on whatever the issue is how you
want to to do a vote um so just to kind
of show you
this document here I'll give you this
when we get a new house built to in a
month or so and then all of these
columns on the far right the action
column will be blank when we start and
then as we start making decisions we'll
start checking off some of these
boxes if you flip to the next page if
you look down
below this is where many of our bills
that came to the
committee how they were added to house
bill to so for instance down at the
bottom under the the other house bill
two amendments there was a bill House
Bill 542 that was referred to this
committee relative to establishing a
position at the department of education
division 2 supported that so we amended
House Bill 2 to add that language into
house bill two so I'll keep track of all
of those bills that are referred to us
as well as House Bill 2 just to make
sure nothing hopefully falls through the
cracks flipping to the next page this is
just showing all the decisions that were
made in house bill one you're going to
get a lot of agency budget requests
they're going to say the governor's
budget didn't fund this or or we need
these technical changes made or whatever
as you start making those decisions and
I'll do the data entry into the budget
system which is somewhat time consuming
so some things I may request that you
consider early you know so that'll give
me time uh I'll also track these for you
so you know how you're doing to date the
decisions you've made Etc um it's a page
two of that document and I will keep a
running total of uh all of your actions
today just so know your overall either
spending or cutting or whatever you're
doing by fund because that'll be
important and then speaking of by
fund the next three pages of this packet
are we'll call them Surplus
statements of the education trust fund
the highway fund and then the fishing
game fund so it's somewhat the
responsibility of this division to
ensure those three funds are balanced in
the way that you want to recommend to
the full committee so like I said this
was what division 2 finalized two years
ago so in the case of the education
trust fund all of the revenues up top
will be a ways and means thing right so
they're going to come up with Revenue
estimates but all the Appropriations
down below that'll be part of your
budget package so when you're
determining adequate education Charter
Schools School building Aid all those
things we're going to keep an eye on how
this is looking for the uh education
any questions to this point I know it's
a lot I don't want to do a whole lot
today diving in but representative
papich M thank you Mr chair not as much
a question as a note to both Miki and
everybody on the committee um last
budget cycle um you know we didn't give
Fish and Game a humongous amount of time
because uh you know they were mostly
self-funded and what not and we had a
lot of bigger fish to fry having been
serving I have served on
statutory committee uh you know Senate
house committee to look at the revenue
funds and provide recommendations and U
some of the things I've learned during
that committee I think will lead to us
having to give a heightened level of
scrutiny to fish and game than we've
done in previous Cycles because they are
very insistent on their need to get
direct Appropriations from the general
fund as part of their budget and that's
a very different type of situation than
what we've had in the past so I just
wanted to give you a heads up that when
we budget for it when you think about it
in terms of workload that we may have
more work there than we had in the past
because of that change in
you uh well I actually have an example
of the fishing game Surplus statement
here in a couple Pages you can see that
um but as far as education back to that
real quick that that is by far the
biggest component of this division in my
opinion because it's uh huge dollar
amount when you talk about adequacy or
education Trust fund expenditures
between Charter Schools adequacy School
building adfas um but it's also a lot of
it state aid so that's usually a tough
decision to make this year is a new year
that you have a new standing committee
in the house an education funding
committee so a lot of bills I look back
two years ago I think we had eight bills
that were first referred to this
committee that now those types of bills
are going to the Ed funding committee
first so in theory house policy should
be vetted out on some of those things
and we have fewer bills maybe with a
house position on them as they come to
this committee um and I know we have two
members on this division who are also on
that committee so there should be a
bridge between the work of of both um so
that'll be hopefully a little bit less
work that's done in this committee as it
should be a a policy determined before
it comes here um so yes the highway fund
too that's that's another one that
perennially is
uh there's there's a lot of decision
making there there's been a lot of
onetime fixes so to speak of the Highway
fund over the years whether it's you
know a temporary change in some revenue
or using different sources of funds to
pay things at the highway fund typically
uh would pay for um I'm expecting to see
that budget come to us not super uh
what's the word flush with money I guess
unless there's you know some massive
changes just based on kind of what we've
seen the last couple years uh and then
fishing game fund um similar thing but
to a smaller uh total dollar amount on
the next page you can see that when the
governor's budget comes out we may or
may not have an audited AER but we'll
have something a preliminary draft that
we can at least build these Surplus
statements off of so you can do your
work education trust fund Highway fund
fishing aame should be pretty good I
would think by that draft that we'll be
using for for Budget work question about
the act for the de wanted to ask it this
morning but it was kind of busy uh is
there any reason they can't we can't
get like the one the UN the incomplete
version that just doesn't have in the
pieces related to Lottery we we probably
will for when we start our work February
15th because the governor to show that
her budget package is balanced we'll
have to use you we'll have balancing
documents there's been preliminary
drafts that have been given that we're I
think that this is the snapshot was
based off of one in November we received
was the last one so we have been getting
some preliminary numbers but knowing
that the final number is is still coming
so it's obviously coming to fiscal to
request an extension at least from this
morning yeah can we um on the fiscal
committee dictate that that we need to
have something released not at least
released to that to the finance
committee I think a request can be made
out if you can dictate necessarily but
we can put we can put yeah we can put a
request in and see what uh the
controller is able to release as far as
a preliminary draft that could be used
but like I said there's not there's not
a ton of use for it for us yet to have
it until the governor's budget comes out
and we'll have whatever she uses which
should be in theory the latest and
greatest at the time that is available
so we should have something for February
you the last piece of paper on this
packet so this is
a a a list that I'll keep as agencies
come in and do their presentation of all
of the requests and outstanding uh items
that either the agencies have asked for
or the bills that exist just kind of a
and I'll update this every single day
that we meet just so it the committee
knows what requests were made and as you
start deciding on them this one
indicates shading so for instance uh the
first block of department of safety
items you can see the item on Row one
was approved the next few were not item
on row 181 1920 were approved so I'll
just keep this as a tracking sheet is a
one pager that this committee can always
look to and say okay these are the
outstanding requests compiled from all
of our agencies as we go
through represent papich M thank you so
just to clarify for everybody Miki the
dark border around something means that
the governor denied that request but we
are being told about the request because
it will probably brought be brought back
to us the on the the lines without the
Border are the ones that as of now the
government the government seems to be
willing to include in her
budget no the I think the borders here
were uh some of these items had multiple
funds so I bordered dark bordered the
total of that request so if you look at
that item 3 four five and six is
actually the same item but it would
affect multiple fund sources so that's
why I have it broken out that way what
the shading represents is uh an item
that division two supported thank you
thank God
iosu uh and then as the budget work goes
through um let's use an example we don't
have Department of uh justice or what I
don't want to use a real department but
let's say someone wants to make a cut to
a department the Department's not going
to come in here and say can you please
cut our budget or so if there's any
change you want to make to the budget
that is not something discussed or
request you can ask me for an amendment
and then I can have some a piece of
paper drafted distributed to the
committee and I would add it to that as
a representative Earth you know
Amendment or whatever just so if there's
something you want to bring for the
committee to consider I can add it to
that list as well so while you're on
that topic of amendments maybe we talk
about this I think you mentioned this to
me in our when we've met earlier
regarding amendments and I think you
indicated that and I just want to get
the committee to agree to this if if if
they agree that if we decide on
amendments you felt in the past it was
okay to vote without actually having the
physical Amendment from OS before us
first of all understand correctly you
what you said to me yep so in the past
uh if if the committee threw a work
session on a bill you know someone wants
to say oh support this but I'd want to
remove lines you know four and five we
can discuss that and I can tell the
committee I'll have that Amendment
drafted you can do a vote on that
pending versus recessing a work session
waiting for an amendment to be drafted
and then come back as long as the the
full committee is okay with that type of
action in the past it's worked for us
and that I'll just email the Amendment
to the full committee after the fact
it's just a more efficient way to
operate so I just like to make sure that
you're all on we're all on board with
that that's that's okay and there and
I'll tell you if there's one that I
think it would be more appropriate to
wait until something's drafted like if
it's you know if we want to off the top
of your head say seven different things
to this amendment I might say well
there's enough change there that let me
get something drafted and bring it back
but so yeah as long as we're all in
agreement then that's that's great yes
representative Muller papovich Muller
Mueller is fine to save time we don't
want to save papovich mu that off fun
but basically look there is also the
fact that in this committee we worked in
a very collegial Manner and if we have a
preliminary vote based on an amendment
and we agree to it and then the
amendment comes out and somebody feels
that they may want to reconsider we will
always be open to bringing back to the
table and retaking the vote or whatever
is needed to address those concerns but
having this process the way we had in
the past worked very well for us and I
would suggest we continue with you know
the accommodations that we'll make for
each other and and that's one other
thing to remember is nothing in this
committee is final everything here is
just a recommendation for a vote across
the hall so there will always be a
chance to fix something or to reconsider
even something we voted for here and
change your mind across the way that
point representative
Murray you'll learn I know eventually
I've been practicing home and not going
to believe but I've actually been going
to the going to the list and and I still
when I have to come up with I freeze so
I'm sorry go ahead not not a big deal um
wasn't the Department of Education
undergoing an audit and where are we on
that there was some issues of discussion
about the Department of Education and an
audit am I misremembering something or I
can speak to that if you want me to um I
assume you're referring to Performance
audits okay I'm on on the legislative
performance audit oversight committee um
I don't actually know if I'm still on it
but I've been on it at least initially
at least for these past few years there
are
two um one related to special education
and one related to the um education
Freedom accounts the special education
one I don't is not yet out but the work
is complete and they're in the final
phase of getting it out and the
education Freedom account one I believe
we
just said yes go forward with with the
approved um scoping statement they Pro
provided last um in December so that's
just essentially just beginning is is if
I recall correctly thank you if that
helps
y I don't have a whole lot else planned
but I'm glad to do I'm glad to do uh
just any open discussion anyone has this
that representative Kelly see she has an
remember um could I just ask for
clarification about how the education uh
funding committee the new committee how
those bills will mesh with Finance if it
will come to this division anything
and so will those bills all be first
committee bills and need to to go
through those deadlines so just because
there's a new committee doesn't mean
that this is the first time that funding
bills or or let me put it a different
way bills that are going to cost money
haven't gone through first committees um
so every bill that might eventually cost
money winds up is noted already as a
second committee bill because they have
to finish that work up earlier those
committees do um and they come to us but
yes so in this case hopefully it's nice
that they have a separate committee pre
know proceeding
ours maybe we can get the bills into a
POS place where they'll more readily
move through Finance as opposed to what
has often times happened in the past and
probably will still happen with
especially with other committees is they
look at themselves as okay we're just a
policy committee we don't really care if
it's going to cost a bazillion dollars
um let's go for it it sounds like a
great idea um I I think that's the
intent and as repres of while our
literat to this morning he's had
conversations with the various
committees to ask them to all take at
least some consideration of costs
associated with the bills that are
coming through their committees um in
their in their thinking does that does
that answer your question if not just
to I think so I'm trying to um mesh it
to how we always well yeah I know that
sitting in the audience I used to know
that you know things would go through uh
first committees but that they weren't
particular to one subject area
particularly but this new committee will
be dealing just with education funding
so I'm wondering how that meshes with
this division oh but it's still first
committee second committee situation
there'll be first committee bills um
just their focus will be on this on the
spending which is great but no it should
be the same process okay they'll go to
the first committee and then they'll
come to our committee and we can do
whatever we want with them just as we
have in the past
um The Hope in my mind I'm one of those
people and this is another one who's
sitting on that committee and I'm told
the reason we're doing this wasn't
exactly excited about it I'll admit that
um is that we hopefully can get the
bills and make so they'll flow more
readily when they come to this group
because um we've been we've been working
with them but yes they'll come here and
we can consider them just as we have in
the past all right that that answers my
question
thank did did you have a question yeah
Mur yeah that's good no I knew the name
not well just I think you sort of
addressed it but just that the potential
exists that they the two the
recommendation coming from the policy
committee will not mesh with the policy
in this committee that we still have to
do our own work on that and that um just
because they're recommending this
doesn't mean that we automatically agree
with that uh there may be conflict
between our focus on policy and what
their focus on policy is I expect that
may not be unreasonable or unlikely
no it's totally correct uh represent
meller thank you Mr chair I just wanted
to say two things one I am excited about
the double committee I'm a glutten for
punishment uh two I completely agree
with what representative Murray said
which is that while we will try to make
sure that the policy committee at least
that particular one does look at costs
at the end of the day because of both
the timing of the process and the nature
of the committee they do not have the
same view to the budget as a whole that
we have here so they may feel that taken
in isolation a policy makes sense but
then when we try to fit it into the
bigger puzzle it doesn't work so it
really doesn't change much I think the
one major beneficial impact besides the
whole workload thing for the education
committee is that hopefully we will get
fewer bills that will come directly to
us so they will act as the first
committee for all education funding
bills and then we'll be able to adjust
the finance committee we won't be asked
to worry about policy and finance at the
same time which has always been
difficult because that's not our core
job so the hope is that it will have
tell represent D you do you have any
thoughts
questions okay all right anyone else I I
was G to say I've not heard I've been
very quiet today so that's going to
change I guess here so so I just wanted
to say thank you in advance to Mr
landrian and his office for the guidance
and help that they're going to provide
us in the coming weeks and just to um
recognize and reflect that um it's been
a very um close workking relationship
with this committee and we're just so
thankful for um you know his
intelligence and his um patience
sometimes with us so thank you in
season representative Bean did you want
to add anything your all side
um I
would said the same thing I I've enjoyed
working through so far and I'm looking
forward to uh a very close relationship
going
forward and I guess if there's nothing
else can we just one thing I was just
going to add I I forgot to say earlier
so I'll send you some links helpful
Links of some documents that are out
there you can familiarize yourself with
but also our our website too anything
that I hand out here I'm going to post
online to a separate division 2 page so
uh do you all know where that is yeah I
I'll send that link to everyone uh um so
anything that is handed out here uh
we'll have it online I'm also going to
try to make an effort to get documents
from agencies in advance of our meetings
and I will email them and post them
online the day of I'll I'll try to email
them to you the night before at least
and then I'll post them online ahead of
our meeting so that way maybe you could
familiarize yourself with the documents
so when you're hearing from the agency
or not seeing this stuff reading it for
the first time as they're testifying and
hopefully that that's been helpful in
the past and hopefully that'll be
helpful again this year and I'll just
add I'm the pain in the neck that
insists on this um I really can't work
with paper um so I do really want all
the people that come before us to
provide their documentation hopefully
the night before or at least the day
before um but at the very least before
the meeting because I only work off of
um the screen so not that you have to
work that way but it's given telling you
how I how I
operate and there will be a lot of paper
for those of you who do work call
especially in this committee I brought
this as a prop you all remember the Ed
funding spreadsheets we'll have a bunch
of those flying around at some point as
well um but yeah I'm I'm looking forward
well anything else for the good of the
committee as my former chairman Edwards
would always
ask everybody good all right I'll
meeting adjourned at
uh
than